[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's going on youtube hey it's
cameron with motion science i am so
happy to have you here today i'm happy
to be here today
how is everyone doing on this fine day
how's everyone doing
uh today we're talking about
creative constraints
how to use creative constraints to
improve
your motion designs
and all that good stuff
but before i get into that i want to
hear from you
do you limit yourself and do you use
constraints when you're creating that's
what i want to know do you limit
yourself to use creative constraints
when you're creating and if so how do
you use constraints please tell me in
the chat box
i want to hear from you i want to know
if any of you are using creative
constraints if you're not that's okay
some people have a hard time
using constraints but it's super super
important for design
while you're telling me that in the chat
box
i'm gonna tell those of you who don't
know who i am my name is cameron i'm the
guy behind emotion science i've been a
motion designer for over 20 years
working in after effects in cinema 4d
i've taught myself motion design i've
taught myself animation so i should say
i've taught myself design and animation
and i have had a very
lucrative and successful career in
motion design
i was a freelancer for over 13 years
i've owned and operated two small
studios post houses i've had the
opportunity to build projects for
studios like prolog films and digital
kitchen and
agencies like publicist and ogilvy and
mather and i've worked with clients like
amazon 343 industries disney microsoft
mtv rca records sony and many many many
many more
so that's a little bit about me if you
don't know who i am
um and i want to tell you guys before i
look here in the chat box to see if any
of you guys have responded to my
question
i do have a new challenge starting next
week on march 21st
it's a five day challenge and it's
called the motion design challenge
how to easily concept and design style
frames without prior knowledge
it's a five day challenge it's live it's
free it's me teaching for five days and
doing q and a's each and every day
it's monday through friday uh it's it's
a lot like this it's where i'm sitting
here talking to you but i have like
powerpoint and i kind of explain things
and i show you my process as well
for designing style frames so if you
want to understand how to create style
frames uh then you need to definitely
check it out
but the only way to check it out
is to register for it it's just not it's
not open to the public it's it's gotta
register it's motionscience.tv
challenge
uh hope to see you there motion science
dot tv
slash
challenge
okay that's what i got for you
um let's go check out the chat box here
really quickly
and see who's here we've got uh jake
what's going on jake happy to have you
here jake
uh let's see here we've also got
uh angelica
uh thanks for the kind words i
appreciate that
happy to have you here as well angelica
uh gp what's going on gp
uh recognize gp from
stylecraft i believe that's the same gp
and i should say jake i recognize you
from career coaching community great to
have you here
lloyd lloyd is in a couple of my
uh
courses and memberships as well
long time subscriber what's going on
lloyd
looking forward to the challenge next
week looking forward to having you
tour what's going on tour greetings from
norway
awesome to have you here
another familiar name
uh brandon
brandon i throw everything out of design
while keeping the brand in mind in the
planning process and then start pulling
back from there interesting brandon so
you you just throw everything into the
design and then you start pulling back
from there that's an interesting way to
approach it
i think personally i would feel
overwhelmed if i was
throwing everything into it but i i
realize you are keeping the brand in
mind so there is a creative constraint
there right that's a theme it's a brand
so that's a constraint for sure
jake is not familiar with the term
creative constraints well i'm going to
teach you all about that jake
it's going to be a short but sweet
lesson today
um
same gp awesome
eva what's going on eva another familiar
name i do not use constraints but i
should i get off track and go down
rabbit holes too easily that is why we
have creative constraints
because we do we go off on these rabbit
holes and it's like we can design
forever and ever and it just it never
ends right i hear so many motion
designers that struggle with
just the endless loop of never finishing
a project
uh because there's no creative
constraints in place
laurent goodtimes hd lauren hey what's
going on laurent great to have you here
uh jake says does that just mean to work
within boundaries depending on brand
standards yeah essentially yes uh-huh
but let's say you don't have
uh a brand standard right going back to
even what brandon said uh let's say that
you're creating spec work or you're
creating work
that doesn't have a brand guide right or
anything like that that's when we can
put creative constraints into place
lauren's been using workflowy ever since
you showcased it in stylecraft yeah
workflow is an amazing program if you
haven't checked out workflow you
definitely do
let's see here
angelica
my major constraint is limited time to
achieve projects due to close deadlines
yeah that's a big constraint right time
constraint we're gonna talk about that
um
and cj what's going on cj
i like the painting in the back thank
you i appreciate that
okay
so uh really great comments
happy to see
um that you guys are using some creative
constraints uh some of you aren't but i
think at the end of the day we always
are a little bit we just may not be
super aware
of what creative constraints are so
let's talk about a few of them okay
let's talk about one let's i have
several of them listed here in my notes
um but the first one i'm going to talk
about is color
really briefly
and
you may say well how what what are you
doing what like what do you mean by
limiting color well i mean limit color
to
maybe three
three colors right
in general and this is just a
generalized guideline but you don't ever
really need to go beyond three colors
you can have a primary color you can
have a secondary color
and you can have an accent color
and with those three
you can design just about anything right
a lot of times i will um in fact you may
have seen some stuff i posted on
instagram recently where i'm using like
one color
um like very monochromatic i love to use
monochromatic colors
uh designs actually with
one color
using two colors you can go a long way
and using a third color like an accent
can take you very far into design so
sometimes we can approach a design as an
as an open color palette
not typically
a good idea
let's try to limit ourselves to colors
and maybe the client is giving you some
brand colors which when you're receiving
a brand guide from a client perfect
there's the colors you have to work with
if you don't receive a brand guide maybe
you're creating something for yourself
pick two or three colors and that's it
and stick to two of those colors for the
majority of the time in that third
accent color
every once in a while
okay let's talk about type
you want to limit yourself on type on
type faces and fonts you want to limit
yourself to two
maybe three
typefaces you don't want to ever go
beyond three typefaces
majority of the time i'm limiting myself
to tube type faces a lot of times you
can get away with one typeface
right you can get away with a serif and
a sans serif
pairing those two together it's called
typeface pairing
super powerful
with what you can design
using a serif and a sans serif
if you need to add a third type face
maybe so maybe like for your headline
your sub head and then the body maybe
the body is is a third type face but
typically one or two type faces is all
you need
another way you can can
use creative constraints is maybe with
shapes right this is an exercise i love
to do
uh whenever i have downtime
and i just feel like creating something
i'll take two or three shapes for
example and i'll say okay maybe i have a
square and a triangle or a square and a
circle what can i create
with that just using those two or three
simple shapes maybe it's just one shape
right maybe i did an exercise in
stylecraft once uh with circles
and it's just all about what can i
create that's interesting just with
circles
and you'll be surprised at by limiting
yourself to maybe one or two shapes your
mind really starts to push itself
creatively like okay what can i do to
make this as interesting as possible
with one or two shapes
you know where can i go if we have an
endless palette of shapes and stars and
squares and rectangles and triangles and
arrows and whatever it is
it's probably gonna be somewhat
challenging to
get pretty creative with that because
there's too many things to choose from
right and this applies to everything
just limiting ourselves
really opens up our creativeness to okay
how can we make this look interesting
you can also limit yourself this sounds
obvious but things like
themes or creatives right like we go
back to uh what brandon was saying like
in a brand guide um that's a that's a
that's a theme right essentially uh in
another way another way of putting it
but um
limit yourself in a theme or a very
specific creative like i'm going to tell
the story of
you know whatever it is but like limit
yourself figure out what that is ahead
of time maybe you need to write that
down
maybe you don't
but limit yourself on themes
uh this is a big one that i think a lot
of people don't actually realize they're
doing but a lot of times when i see
work that's put in front of me and asked
to critique it
i'll see like a theme of whatever it is
happening and then all of a sudden
there's like a secondary theme that
comes in maybe even for something as
simple as a transition right
where
it's completely a completely separate
theme like maybe it's a glitchy
transition
you know mixed in with this very
uh
parallax type
you know maybe we see a two or three
photos more apparent this is a totally
random example but maybe we see some
parallaxing happening right and we're
moving through these images and also
there's a transition that's glitchy it
really has nothing to do with what we
were just looking at it's like
introducing a second theme
uh to our our piece and
that's something we want to stay away
from right we want to limit ourself on
the themes that we're trying to portray
uh another huge one this is key time in
length okay
again i see a lot of motion designers
try to tackle 30 second projects
a minute long projects don't do that
right again now this is coming back to
to more of your own personal work or
work maybe you're creating for a demo
reel or something like that or just work
you want to create anyways you know
limit yourself in that length
of overall time now if a client comes to
you and says we need a 60-second piece
well you have to deliver a 60-second
piece right but they're also they're
limiting you again it comes back to
their brand guide their requirements
what they want from you and they're
giving you a time constraint right so
now why not do that for yourself why not
limit your own overall length of a piece
i tend to prefer 10 seconds or less for
a piece
and that's what i would recommend to
anyone who's creating personal spec work
limit yourself to 10 seconds or less
less even five seconds think about
putting a demo reel together with spec
work
typically your shots on a dimmer are
pretty quick right a couple seconds long
at most they're typically not more than
five seconds long unless you have a very
slow paced demo reel so limit the length
of your motion design pieces that is
huge you're going to find that by
limiting that time the overall length
that you can really spend a lot more
time refining the details and getting
things those subtleties in there that
make your piece that much better
imagery
okay
find three or four images and just run
with that
right
i just did some style frame designs and
i picked
one main image
to work with and i picked two or three i
think it's actually two secondary images
and one of those was the texture and
this is actually something i'm going to
talk about on a in a later lesson but
i had three
image assets
and i built an entire style frame around
that by limiting my my image assets it
opens up my create creativeness to
to
problem solve and to make my image as
powerful as possible with just a very
few images this applies also to just
assets in general
maybe you want to limit yourself to one
image one video one typeface
one or two colors
limiting the number of assets that
you're working with
is a creative constraint right and this
can kind of go back to to covering like
i said multiple things imagery
shapes type color whatever it is but
just limiting your overall number of
assets is huge
plugins
do not use third-party plugins
uh unless you absolutely have to or
unless you're further on in your skill
set stay away from third-party plugins
unless you need them for a very specific
use case
okay so like let's say you're doing a
project and it requires
um
some physics to it right there's a
plugin called newton
out there that does physics within after
effects so something like that kind of
project yeah i would look into
um
you know a third-party plug-in like
newton or for me personally i like to
use a lot of glows in my work and i find
that after effects's glow just isn't
quite there for me so i'll use a
third-party plug-in with a globe it's a
very specific use case
uh don't get wrapped up in having to buy
these different third-party plugins and
ultimately i would say stay away from
them as you're learning
design or trying to get better in motion
design stay away from third-party
plugins after effects has so many
effects built into it which brings me to
another creative constraint
use the built-in after effects
effects
sparingly
and use them at the end
of your project right i like to use them
for the finishing stage you can design
everything
around
you know whatever it is that you're
designing design it and at the very end
bring in those plug-ins those effects
that are built into after effects like
the glow right to add a little bit of
lighting to your image
uh i like to finish pieces with adding
grain or noise i like to finish pieces
with just a little bit of blur
i like to finish some pieces with
chromatic aberration it just depends
but use them very sparingly at the end
to finish that piece
don't rely on effects and third-party
plug-ins to
think that they're going to create this
amazing design for you because they
won't they're just going to
create additional
frustrations for you
as you're trying to design and i'm
trying to alleviate some of these
frustrations by
limiting the creative assets that you're
using
and the last one i want to talk about
very quickly and this is the biggest one
of all
limit
add creative constraints
to
your time your time we talked about the
length overall length of something but
limit your time
what that is depends on whatever it is
you're working on
it could be a couple hours it could be a
day it could be a week but you need to
set a limit
right a lot of times for myself
i usually spend a day or less
it's usually a half day or less on
designing something if i want to
experiment with something
maybe have an idea for a course
or just something i want to put out
there
and i want to create an image or two for
it or an animation or two for it
i'm going to limit myself to about half
a day
and then i'm going to step away from it
i'm going to come back the next day or
the day after that with some fresh eyes
and then look at it and then decide this
is good or it's not good and if it's
good enough i'm going to refine it a
little bit more and add some effects and
things like that at that point but i'm
limiting myself right again something i
see motion designers doing all the time
is just going over and over things
hour by hour day by day week by week and
something is never finished
so you need to set a limit for your time
a couple hours a day a day a week
whatever it is
i would never go over a week on anything
that's short
for yourself so that's what i got
those are some creative constraints that
you need to keep in mind
when
designing and i promise you guys if you
if you do this
if you use creative constraints you will
be shocked at uh what you can create
some of my best creations
throughout my career in both style frame
design and animation
has been because i'm very limited on
what i can use i actually would love it
when a client would come to me
and say
we got
this one image
we got to fill
15 seconds of time we got an audio track
and we got this typeface what can you do
and they weren't expecting a whole lot
for me right but because i was i loved
that challenge of just having this very
small amount of assets to work with uh i
could usually shock a client
with what i could pull off with that so
it just it
it helps you know it pushes you to think
creatively but over time
your brain
starts to kind of rewire itself to uh to
get very quick at doing this kind of
stuff and being a lot more creative
right
so it's definitely a good practice to
put into place
i had a few more comments here if you
guys have any questions i would love to
hear from you regarding creative
constraints that would be awesome
um
gp said pretty new to motion but as a
graphic designer either the brief keeps
me constrained professionally or i write
sketch first plan i also start with many
assets but inevitably always scale back
yeah i mean you know gp that's a great
point it's
like when i do start to
pull assets for a project i typically
pull quite a few right and it just
depends on the project of what i'm
pulling
but i'll pull quite a few but then i'll
very quickly start eliminating and say
no no no
and
a great example
when i was designing a style frame for
next week's challenge
um i started initially with an idea a
theme of a cold war
uh i wanted to do like this kind of
vintage cold war piece and so i pulled
some imagery some some soldiers and some
uh documents and things like that
because it was for a a fake uh tv show
uh promo i was putting together a style
frame
and it started cold war but it very
quickly morphed into like an old western
type of thing so i had pulled this cold
war imagery and then i started finding
myself pulling uh like old cowboy
vintage kind of things and it quickly
was like okay get rid of all this cold
war stuff here's here's three cowboy
things i can use
and
then i was very quickly able to design
the style frame based on that
i don't typically write
out
what i'm gonna do i know a lot of
designers who do
i just i've never been real big on
writing
same with sketching i've never been one
to sketch i can't sketch right i wish i
could
but for a lot of motion designers
writing and sketching the plan first is
a great plan of attack
but great that you're starting with
assets and you're definitely scaling
them back so that's great
uh brandon three color is definitely the
way to go always use gradients for those
with those to create a new look at of
color through that's awesome tip great
tip
uh cj being colorblind using a limited
monochrome color palette works really
well that's a great
tip as well
a lot of designers are color blind it's
really surprising
uh
okay tour as far as critical constraints
mine would be to currently find myself
between jobs and doing some freelance
work for the time being it's fine for
now but i as inspiring emotions are
i believe i have a much better peace of
mind and consequently less worries more
breathing for creative with a full-time
job not have to cons yeah i mean that's
a little bit different than what we're
talking about today though tor um
i think if i'm understanding that right
but uh yeah always aspire to be better
always aspire to be better
uh that's all we can do that's
my it's been my mantra since day one
i've always wanted to get better
at motion design at my craft and
that is what's also helped push me to
get better
to improve my craft
uh eva no questions here heartfelt
thanks for everything you do for this
community of course
okay well
looks like i am out of questions so
again i want to talk uh i just want to
put this up here really briefly again
if i can there we go free 5 day
challenge starts next week motion
science dot tv slash challenge
i hope to see many of you there
i've had a lot of people register so far
i think it's going to be an amazing
challenge
i know it's going to be amazing
challenge i've put a lot of work into it
and
i'm really proud of what uh what i've
come up with for it i'm still actually
putting the finishing touches on it this
week
so
there's always that i also want to let
you guys know that stylecraft
if you've checked out starcraft i know
many of you here are in starcraft and if
you're thinking about joining stylecraft
the registration is opening up
march 24th and it closes april 2nd
so this is your opportunity to get in
wide registration while it's open there
will be a limited number of seats
because i have a lot of people wanting
to get in so
uh i just want to wrap with this oh
actually see jake said great stuff
really like time constraint
uh nothing worse than beating a
dead horse losing passion for project
thank you looking forward to the next
week's class awesome
i would have another question from
abdo is starcraft more designer after
effects so it's it's both actually it's
uh it's
heavy on after effects
a little bit on cinema 4d light
uh and a lot of starcraft revolves
around design right but it's it's we're
putting our design into motion and the
vast majority of the lessons so i'm
teaching you
why it's important to understand design
and why it's important that you have
good design fundamentals under your belt
to become to be a really great motion
designer
a lot of motion designers
uh are focused on the animation side and
that's great
but you also need to understand the
design side right that's why we are a
motion designer we understand motion and
design
even if you don't want to design right
it's important that you understand the
design side of things because
let's say you start with a composition
that's been designed for you and laid
out and it's there and you animate it
right and you're when you animate you
start moving assets around you start
moving things around the screen and you
want to understand where things can end
up on screen where they can be to make
the image the composition still
aesthetically pleasing to our eye
and that's super super important so it's
important that you understand design
principles uh principles so that uh your
animation can look even that much better
so we do
some animation for sure i focus more on
cinematic motion which means it's more
types of movements that are
slower
and just more epic i would say versus
teaching you things like
you know here's how to animate a
character or here's how to
use the speed graph in in great detail
we've we've talked a little bit about
that but um definitely more on the
design side so
um okay
so again wrapping this up guys always
remember the best way to get better at
motion graphics is to keep creating and
practicing watch other people's work
learn from it that is key and find ways
you can improve upon it stay motivated
experiment with new techniques and above
all else have fun with your work
with enough practice you'll become a
master of the craft and produce stunning
visuals yourself that can capture
people's attention you have a very
unique skill
that very few people possess
i want to say thank you for being here
today as always i'm cameron and this is
motion science